les chars virage s'impose au sommet du
mont ventoux le maillot jaune lance
armstrong arrivé troisième
la féliciter
mille deux cents policiers
supplémentaires sur la route c'est une
des mesures du plan de lutte contre
l'insécurité routière que présentera en
septembre le ministre gilles de robien
jean pierre raffarin réaffirme la
responsabilité de l'état français dans
la rafle du vel d'hiv il ya 60 ans le
premier acte de la shoah c'est jouer ici
at il dit ce matin lors de la cérémonie
de commémoration pamiers guinguette
sable et transats jusqu'au 18 août la
rive droite de la seine a des allures de
riviera ou presque l'opération initiée
par le maire de paris devrait séduire
nous en parlerons tout à l'heure avec
bertrand delanoë qui est notre invité en
direct de la plage
madame monsieur bonsoir c'est une
victoire de seigneur pour richard
virenque
car en portant autour de francs le tout
en solitaire l'ascension du mont ventoux
à l'issue d'une étape de 221 km le
français a devancé d'une minute 57 le
russe alexandre botcharov et de deux
minutes 19 l'américain lance armstrong
qui a déclaré à l'arrivée le vent taux
est un col difficile c'est trop dur
compte rendu de l'étape julia est riche
on est abdel oliech dont les gestes de
richard virenque
il y a toujours un je ne sais quoi du
revanchard
une fierté aujourd'hui toute légitime
virenque a vaincu le ventoux à l'envi au
courage au terme d'une échappée de 196
km ils devancent armstrong il devance
les autres cet exploit là on en
reparlera virenque s'est fait une place
dans la légende 196km baigné par le
soleil du vaucluse 196 km à parcourir
pour onze hommes parti de blancs au pied
du ventoux huit minutes d'avancé sur le
peloton c'est beaucoup mais le long de
l'ascension on est toujours indécis avec
la locomotive johnson
ça fait que je pense g strings qui va
arriver encore au premier qui va
dépasser plus on croit rêver l'athénien
messieurs ne vous inquiétez pas pour lui
il était ensuite armé ci doit en rester
qu'un ce sera virenque le français part
seul et va résister résister parce que
derrière la bataille est lancée et le
qui accélère en seconde aussi les un peu
plus fort encore
le duel est lancé il va tourner à
l'avantagé du français quelle belle
victoire
line et richard virenque une fois de
plus ses portes en ce moment en richard
et manque autant pour moi pour l'équipe
de moi et surtout pour tous ceux qui
croyaient en moi et c'est énorme de
gagner dans le du panache encore du
panache toujours du panache le grimpeur
a conquis limites
richard virenque a dompté le mont chauve
et au cours de cette étape un enfant de
12 ans a été blessé il a été renversée
par un motard de la garde républicaine
qui encadraient le tour de france
mercredi dernier un petit garçon de 7
ans a été tué par une voiture de la
caravane du tour rappelons les règles
élémentaires de prudence il faut rester
sur le bas côté de la route lorsque
passe le tour de france le ministre des
transports gilles d'euros brin gilles de
robien présentera en septembre un plan
d'action pour la sécurité routière
entre autres mesures la création d'un
corps spécial de police routière avec un
effectif supplémentaire de 1200
policiers et gendarmes
christelle bertrand yannick aroussi
présence répression contrôle le mot
d'ordre n'est pas nouveau et comme ses
prédécesseurs le gouvernement raffarin
veut faire baisser le nombre de tués sur
la route
plus de 8000 parents comme les
etats-unis la france veut une police de
la route consacrer à 100% à cette tâche
les 1200 personnes qui sont annoncées
par le ministre de l'intérieur nicolas
sarkozy c'est 1200 personnes uniquement
pour la police de la route policiers
nationaux et gendarmes et donc ce sont
des effectifs en plus pour faire de la
prévention et pour faire de l'art et
passion les voitures pourraient être
équipés de boîtes noires comme dans les
avions et les camions de quoi satisfaire
les associations contre la violence
routière
il n'y aura pas en effet deux
révolutions de sécurité routière en
france sans la boîte noire d'une part
qui permettra de connaître les
circonstances de l'accident et qui fera
foi qui mettra une certaine pression
tout de même sur le conducteur d'une
part d'autre part sans le bridage des
moteurs
le ticket de péage pourrait aussi
devenir un bon indicateur de vitesse
il suffirait d'examiner le temps de la
distance parcourue entre deux paiements
une mesure diversement appréciée par les
automobilistes
est-ce qu'ils vont prendre en compte les
temps de repos tout ça ce sera pendant
qu'on y est
ouais je pense que ça peut être pas mal
je pense que c'est vraiment un peu de
courage
c'est une fille qui à l'entrée on
expliquer la sortie l'alcool au volant
est aussi une préoccupation le seuil
toléré est aujourd'hui de 0 5 gramme
d'alcool par litre de sang
il pourrait être ramenée à 0 pour les
jeunes conducteurs
ces mesures seront présentées en
septembre au premier semestre 2002 le
nombre de tués sur la route a encore
augmenté
jean pierre raffarin qui assisté ce
matin à la commémoration de la rafle du
vel d'hiv a insisté sur la
responsabilité de l'état français
il ya 61 ans les 16 et 17 juillet 1942
13 mille français de confession juive
avait été arrêtés à leur domicile par
des policiers et des gendarmes français
et rassembler dans l'ancien vélodrome
d'hiver aujourd'hui démoli avant d'être
déportés dans les camps de concentration
laurent hakim et jacques gérard ont
assisté à la cérémonie où ils ont
rencontré un rescapé qui à l'époque
avaient pu s'échapper
soixante ans plus tard il n'y a plus de
vel d'hiv
à la place ce monument rappelle
l'horreur des deux journées diabolique
de juillet 42 des couples des femmes des
enfants soumis traqué puis embarqué par
la police française aux ordres de
l'occupant
treize mille arrestations en deux jours
une cadence infernale près de trois
cents pour chaque heure qui s'écoule est
ce matin la foule était nombreuse et
émue comme raymond allistene il avait
dix ans lorsqu'il s'est échappé du vel
d'hiv avec son frère aîné leurs parents
n'ont pas eu cette chance il ya 60 ans
et justement le lien personnel que vous
avez avec cette cet événement le lien
pertes belge c'était affreux
et que vous avez vécu à l'intérieur
j'étais ce matin il y avait des prières
des chants des fleurs des honneurs
militaires et des discours des mots
forts pour rappeler le rôle épouvantable
de la france de vichy dans cet épisode
de l'holocauste
oui le président de la république a eu
raison de dénoncer au nom de la france
les complices des nazis oui la folie
criminelle de l'occupant a été secondée
par des français par l'état français
oui le premier acte de lachor sénat j'ai
joué ici avec la complicité de l'état
français une civilisation qui oublie son
passé se condamne à le revivre ajoutera
encore jean pierre raffarin affirmant la
fermeté de l'état face aux actes
antisémites et son attachement au
travail de mémoire en italie 10
personnes ont été tuées et 47 blessées
dans le déraillement d'un train hier
soir le train reliant palerme en sicile
à venise au nord de l'italie a déraillé
près de messine avec à son bord 190
passagers dont de nombreux étrangers
l'un des conducteurs du train figurent
au nombre des victimes arnauld miguet
les images aériennes témoignent de
l'ampleur et de la violence de la
catastrophe survenue hier dans la ville
de rome étant il est 19 heures le train
express palerme venise des rails
provoquant l'effondrement d'un immeuble
et la destruction d'une maison 190
passagers étaient à bord 17 wagons de la
compagnie trenitalia arrivé une heure
après l'accident les secouristes
parviennent à extraire de ces amas de
ferraille huit corps trois italiens dont
l'un des conducteurs quatre marocains et
une jeune allemande
il ya aussi de nombreux blessés il y
avait des corps gisant partout autour de
moi c'était tous des gens criaient
les enfants pleuraient tout le monde
était coincé dans mon wagon qu'un stade
les causes exactes du drame ne sont pas
encore déterminées mais on a relevé que
la voie ferrée à 300 mètres en amont de
l'accident était endommagée en pause la
vétusté des installations ferroviaires
de cette région des plus pauvres de
l'italie le drame d'hier est la pire
catastrophe depuis 1979 déjà quelques
kilomètres de là deux trains étaient
entrés en provisions durant douze
personnes au canada les journées
mondiales de la jeunesse qui débute dans
trois jours à toronto devraient
rassembler 300 mille catholiques c'est à
dire quatre fois moins que prévu
le pape qui est actuellement dans sa
résidence à castel gandolfo en italie
devraient les rejoindre mardi
il enchaînera avec un voyage de dix
jours qui devrait le mener au guatemala
et au mexique malgré une chance une
santé très chancelante
florence malik si dieu le veut je vous
donne rendez vous mardi à toronto
c'est avec ces paroles que jean paul ii
a accueilli aujourd'hui dans sa
résidence d'été des pèlerins venus le
rencontrer avant leur départ pour le
canada
je salue cordialement les invitant à
prier pour eugène qui sait la chambre
encore la maladie et la vieillesse
chaque jour plus pesante n'entament pas
la détermination du pas mais son état de
santé précaire et difficile à gérer pour
le vatican son entourage doit sans cesse
s'adapter
ainsi lors de son dernier voyage en
bulgarie et en azerbaïdjan papamobile
modifié élévateur mécanique plateforme
roulante
toutes les astuces sont utilisés pour
lui épargner les efforts physiques
ce petit coin de paradis c'est
strawberry island l'île aux fraises à
100 km de toronto
elle appartient à la congrégation de
saint basile le pape sy reposera
longuement entre ses apparitions
publiques
durant les journées mondiales de la
jeunesse dans le calme le plus total
et puis après le canada ce sera le bois
témala le mexique
vingt-quatre mille kilomètres 30 heures
de vol des foules chaleureuse et
pressante
un nouveau défi pour ce pape qui semble
toujours trouvé en lui d'ultimes
ressources depuis aujourd'hui la taxe
intérieure sur les produits pétroliers
totalement rétabli ce qui entraîne déjà
une légère hausse de l'essence à la
pompe laurent fabius avait en effet
accordé en 2000 à bonus fiscal pour
compenser les prix du pétrole brut
explications vincent fourcade 2 centimes
d'euros en plus par litre d'essence
l'augmentation est discrète mais il
s'agit bien là de la première hausse
d'impôts de l'été je pense que le
gouvernement aurait tort de s'en priver
parce que
les français continueront à rouler avec
leur véhicule en bas ce qui donne d'à
côté il faut bien qu'il récupère de
l'autre cette hausse
la conséquence directe de l'abandon d'un
bonus fiscal et d'une réforme de la tp
paie la taxe intérieure sur les produits
pétroliers
les trois quart du prix de l'essence
jusque là cette taxe était flottante
quand les cours du pétrole s'envolaient
la taxe diminué 10 versa un véritable
amortisseur pour garantir des prix
stables à la pompe
mutinda pays pévèlois en fait très peu
fonctionné et par conséquent depuis mars
2001 les prix ont fluctué uniquement en
fonction du prix des produits et la tbb
flottante pas joué en principe cette
réforme se veut un dollar car pour
compenser l'alourdissement fiscal bercy
table sur la bonne tenue de l'euro face
au dollar car un dollar en baisse
entraîne une chute du prix du brut
côté consommateur c'est l'inquiétude si
le dollar repart ou su prix du baril de
pétrole remonte nous n'avons plus de
systèmes amortisseurs donc ça va se
traduire immédiatement chez dire quasi
obligatoirement mécaniquement par une
hausse des prix des carburants
cette réponse devrait rapporter à bercy
plus d'un milliard d'euros par an de
quoi financer pour moitié les baisses
d'impôts promises par le gouvernement
demain le ministre de la santé jean
françois mattei va rencontrer les
syndicats de médecins et d'agents
hospitaliers pour trouver des
assouplissements à l'application des 35
heures est un pourri en effet payer une
partie des rtt non prises pour tenir
compte du manque de personnel notamment
l'été les services en effet en beaucoup
de difficultés à fonctionner normalement
comme le montre ce reportage de martin
ouais c'est valérie lucas à l'hôpital de
colonne le week-end aux urgences de
l'hôpital louis mourier en banlieue
parisienne une activité peu soutenu pas
de grosses blessures
et pourtant les malades estiment ne pas
assez voir les infirmiers qui viennent
régulièrement
pour voir si on va bien l'hôpital est
passés aux 35 heures depuis quatre mois
il devrait y avoir 22 embauches mais
jusqu'ici peu de choses ont changé dans
les services le plus marquant c'est le
temps en commun entre les équipes
on ne transmet plus que les informations
essentielles ou 549 la dame on la
transfère dans l'autre servi dans
l'autre aile avant pour permettre de
fermer progressivement les normes
d'accord en raison du manque de
personnel qui a dans le
dans le salles y entrant réduction du
temps de travail et vacances du côté de
l'administration on cherche fébrilement
du personnel en dehors de l'hôpital
il accorde la surveillante qui est
d'accord pour une aide soignante
évidemment elle frappa le travail d'une
infirmière mais au moins elle elle
pourra dire oui oui vous êtes toujours
recherche
la remplaçante sera trouvée avant la fin
de la journée pas facile donc de prendre
ses rtt pour compenser une partie des
jours pourraient être indemnisées les
autres iv dans un compte épargne temps
une solution qui ne fait pas l'unanimité
et financières non parce que on va payer
des impôts là dessus donc c'est pas très
intéressant un compte épargne temps
moi j'aimerais bien pouvoir prendre en
fait mes rtt
quand j'en ai besoin en attendant
l'arrivée des nouvelles infirmières qui
sortiront des écoles en septembre
pendant l'été à colombes
on a fermé un lit sur 5 pour la première
fois en france un spot publicitaire de
25 secondes montre un homme atteint du
cancer du poumon filmé par sa femme
quelques jours avant sa mort c'est le
comité national contre le tabagisme qui
est à l'origine de cette campagne
destinée à frapper les esprits
hélène verne
cet homme là plus que cinq jours à vivre
c'est juste un fumeur
il a commencé à 14 ans un âge où l'on se
prend immortels mais il n'a jamais pu
s'arrêter 1,39 entre chaque année en
france la cigarette est responsable de
60 mille des 50 qu'il donnait à voir la
souffrance d'un malade montrer ce que
l'on ne voit jamais c'est l'objectif de
cette nouvelle campagne publicitaire
au lieu d'avoir une image positive de la
cigarette on a une image de la réalité
qui n'est pas seulement un mot et c'est
patients meurent dans les hôpitaux et ne
sont pas vues du public devant
l'indifférence générale face aux dangers
du tabac la france s'inspire des
techniques de communication anglo saxon
pour créer l'effet de surprise
déjà le mois dernier une campagne
inédite lister les différentes
substances chimiques contenues dans un
produit de consommation courante qui
n'est autre que la cigarette
en un mot rappeler aux fumeurs la
dangerosité du produit le tabac et pas
seulement en france la première cause de
décès évitable
c'est pas seulement en europe le tabac
est la première cause de décès est vital
c'est pour le monde entier où le tabac
est devenue aujourd'hui la première
cause de décès évitable à kazan dans le
monde chaque année kg 4 millions de
personnes meurent d'avoir trop fumé dans
ce mortal c'est demain que nicolas
sarkozy présentera le premier bilan des
groupements d'intervention régionaux
il y en a 28 ans france ou policiers
gendarmes douaniers et agents du fisc
doivent travailler en commun une
collaboration qui n'est pas évidente
tant ces différents corps de l'état ont
des cultures divergentes
une collaboration critiquée aussi par
les syndicats de magistrats yann fronty
éric perrin et patrice brugère 300
hommes sur le terrain les gir rentrer en
action
le retour de la police dans des
quartiers jusque-là oublier pour les uns
de la poudre aux yeux des coûts de
communication pour les eaux
un mois et demi après leur création les
gir font débat il vaudrait mieux
vraiment renforcer la police judiciaire
que mettre en place comme cela
des centaines de policiers de gendarmes
qui débarque dans des quartiers
populaires pour un résultat absolument
ridicule quelques dizaines de grammes de
haschich et trois appareils
électroménagers s'est pas vraiment des
résultats très intéressants compte tenu
des forces mobilisées pas d'accord sur
la forme pas d'accord non plus sur le
fond d'après le syndicat de la
magistrature et la cgt police
deux problèmes sont posés la création
des gir serait inconstitutionnelle et la
séparation des pouvoirs seraient bafoués
le conseil d'état devra trancher nicolas
sarkozy lui se dit peu sensible à la
polémique
moi j'agis ce qui est la seule chose qui
m'intéresse est d'éradiquer la
délinquance de leurs portes de porter à
cette délinquance les coups les plus
fous les plus forts puis le reste vous
savez la cgt police et le syndicat de la
magistrature
ils font ce qu'ils ont toujours fait
est-ce que ça a été efficace dans le
passé
jusqu'à présent peu de voix s'étaient
élevées pour critiquer les premières
initiatives de nicolas sarkozy une
période de bienveillance aujourd'hui
terminé les gir sont donc condamnés à
obtenir des résultats à collioure dans
les pyrénées-orientales le centre
national d'entraînement commando désarmé
a ouvert ses portes au public pour une
journée petits et grands sont venus
visiter le fort miradou où ils étaient
invités à défier les instructeurs dans
cette école héritière des bataillons de
choc véronique ghadi l'yonne et pascal
pons le décor c'est comme pour les
costumes sont de l'armée terre et les
acteurs sont tous des civils
amateurs de sensations fortes de
malformations l'intérêt personnel est un
peu rude mollet puis un peu gauche
instructeur appartiennent aux snec
centre national d'entraînement commando
d'habitude ici on forme des cadres de
l'armée ou de la gendarmerie
aujourd'hui ce sont des touristes j'aime
le risque que j'aime bien vivre à un
petit peu ce fait vibrer un peu c'est
c'est sympa
voilà là on avait quand même ah oui mais
en plus elle est intégrée à regarder
quand même autour de nous qui sont plus
proches tout proche des gens c'est sympa
les journées pour tous leurs postes
c'est l'heure mais oui mais version
décontractée une vraie kermesse avec de
fausses grenades et de vraie cible les
enfants at war et ussel
photo co c'est très bien voilà engagé
pour cinq ans les commandos demain tu te
présentes à 8 heures en proposant
sécurité tant qu'en tire ça bouge un
point ça dédia pain et ça ça fait mal
si on a besoin de recruter dans l'armée
puisque maintenant on n'a que des
professionnels montrer aux à la société
civile que ce qu'on fait c'est un métier
à part entière et donc recruté appeler
les gens là ont leurs 10 ans ont regardé
ce qu'on fait c'est sympa venez chez
nous leur ferait métier si le commando
mais le snec ne veut plus être une
citadelle fermé en perdant c'est appeler
le centre atert du 500 hommes
il est urgent de resserrer les liens
avec la société civile dans la région de
cambrai dans le nord de la france la
nappe phréatique affleure aujourd'hui le
socle des maisons ce qui entraîne des
inondations systématique des cars
les habitants de plusieurs villages ne
comprennent pas ce phénomène et demande
à être classé en zone de catastrophe
naturelle
reportage frédéric dion est il un cac40
d'eau l'an passé il y en avait 40
centimes est et ça fait combien de temps
tu y ait de l'eau quatre mois quatre
mois
oh oui et depuis 15 mois l'eau est
partout dans les sous sols et dans les
caves de rieux en cambrésis
comme dans ceux de la presque totalité
des villages alentours les deux derniers
hivers très pluvieux ont fait remonter
la nappe phréatique une masse d'eau qui
affleure désormais à quelques dizaines
de centimètres à peine sous le niveau du
sol résultat dans certains quartiers
plus une seule cave n'a été à sec depuis
le printemps 2001
c'est tout vent table c'est tout va et
puis plus fort vous toucherez les murs
toute l'humidité maman terre et les
dégâts sont pas pour l'instant mais les
dégâts c'est dans les années à venir
s'il n'y a pas de solution des dégâts il
y en a pourtant déjà et il
il y à 3 400 quinette de baisse minée
par l'humidité les maisons s'affaisse
menace de s'écrouler et doivent parfois
être évacués et aux yeux de certains les
pluies ne sont pas les seuls
responsables dans un rayon de six
kilomètres plus haut qu'un château d'eau
ne sommes dans la nappe phréatique
les eaux sont pompés à plus de 10 km 10
il y at-il un rapport et me semble sans
doute sans doute les châteaux d'eau de
la commune ont en effet cessé de pompey
il ya quelques années lorsque la nappe
phréatique a été polluée par des
nitrates
les experts ont beau affirmer que cela
n'a eu que très peu d'incidence la
théorie séduit beaucoup à rieux où l'on
attend désormais que le village soit
déclarés en état de catastrophe
naturelle
paris sa plage ses palmiers ses transats
sait désormais ce qui est proposé aux
parisiens sur les quais de la seine
jusqu'au 18 août l'opération lancée par
la mairie de paris
paris plage s'étend sur trois kilomètres
autour de l'île de la cité et de notre
dame
ambiance riviera donc mais baignade
interdite et c'est pauline rêve naze qui
est à la plage
c'est un ordinaire d'une plage en été
les pâtes et les transats la crème
solaire et les bateaux mouches car nous
sommes bien à paris entre l'île de la
cité et les tuileries trois kilomètres
de littoral à ménager pendant tout l'été
c'est beau de musique les vacances de
pâques plupart en plantation des tumeurs
pogo 150 parasols et 300 transat pour se
détendre comme peut l'être encore mieux
je m'attendais à un petit peu mieux que
ça mais c'est sympa quand même super
bien et sont contents et puis fellow à
peu près beau une station balnéaire en
plein coeur de paris on s'y croirait et
on se prendrait presque à rêver en
regardant le ciel
mais pour y croire vraiment mieux vaut
fermer les yeux et oublier la foule le
des petits on n'a pas de place ne peut
pas bronzer on a pris des couleurs
ailleurs on aimerait bien continuer mais
ça marche pas c'est très bien des
seigneurs sans pollution
sans pollution en bas peut-être mais en
hausse sur les quais la fermeture des
berges risque de provoquer l'engorgement
car chaque jour 200 mille véhicules
empruntent ces voies pour les opposants
à paris-plage mené par le président de
l'automobile club
la politique de la mairie c'est du sable
aux yeux bertrand delanoë bonsoir alors
au sport on le voit les premières
réactions sont très favorables beaucoup
beaucoup de monde dès le premier jour
sur votre place des filières on me dit
600 milles mais sait pas si le chiffre
exact
en tout cas j'ai vu beaucoup de gens
heureux heureux d'être dans la beauté de
paris ensemble des parisiens des
touristes des habitants de banlieue je
rappelle qu'il ya quand même beaucoup de
parisiens d'habitants de la région
parisienne qui ne partent pas en
vacances
c'est d'abord pour eux et puis si ça
donne une image de paris plus ouvert
plus dynamique plus attirante
c'est peut-être bien aussi pour
l'économie parisienne est-ce que l'an
prochain vous pourriez étendre la plage
rive gauche de la seine puisqu'on voyait
beaucoup beaucoup de monde
on va voir en tout cas avec mes
collaborateurs et je veux saluer le
personnel de la ville de paris qui a
travaillé par centaines des nuits
entières avec bonne humeur générosité
compétences pour offrir ce plaisir à
tous ceux qui nous visitent aujourd'hui
avec des collaborateurs donc tout à
l'heure on noté ce qui manquait ce qui
n'allait pas on essaie d'entendre aussi
les suggestions donc si on recommence
l'an prochain ce que je souhaite
nous essaierons d'améliorer comme nous
améliorons cette année par rapport à
l'an dernier
est ce que par exemple on a ciselé from
parisien utiliser davantage les
transports en commun forcément il y aura
davantage d'autobus en circulation
écoutez je vais vous dire les maires
précédents s'étaient fixé comme objectif
de faire baisser la circulation
automobile de 5 % 6 ans nous l'avons
fait baisser de 3% maintenant et c'est
pas un caprice la l'automobile c'est la
pollution c'est la santé des plus
fragiles et en particulier des enfants
donc faire une ville pour les habitants
pour ceux qui se déplacent par
différents modes qui ne pollue pas c'est
vivre ensemble d'une manière plus
civilisé parce que l'essentiel c'est
quand même la santé est ce que ça veut
dire à terme bertrand delanoë que vous
allez améliorer la circulation pour les
vélos parce que parfois la cohabitation
autobus
vélo dans les mêmes voix c'est pas
toujours simple ça s'est amélioré mais
bien sûr que nous voulons corriger
améliorée avec la préfecture de police
nous travaillons régulièrement sur
chaque chantier nous trouvons des
compromis et tout doucement avec une
volonté inébranlable
nous rendrons paris au parisien et à
caen à quand la baignade avec la plage
parce que pour l'instant évidemment on
va se baigner dans la seine
d'abord il ya déjà beaucoup de jeux pour
enfants beaucoup d'activités sportives
culturelles et de la musique de la
musique classique à l'accordéon à la
guinguette en passant par le jazz ou la
techno et puis c'est vrai je crois que
j'ai oublié votre question parce que
j'étais un peu long mais c'est vrai
aussi que nous voulons que à paris on
puisse se baigner non pas dans la seine
et dans des piscines sur la scène et
donc j'ai promis dans ce mandat de faire
deux piscines dans la scène avec de
l'eau douce évidemment une ce travers le
campus que nous créons avec l'état à
paris rive gauche dans la grande
bibliothèque françois mitterrand et une
autre vers l'ouest de paris dont compte
on se baignera dans ce cadre magnifique
merci beaucoup aux bertrand delanoë
d'avoir était notre invité ce soir est
bonne promenade sur paris plages
merci michael schumacher a remporté
aujourd'hui le grand prix de france à
magny cours ce qui le place pour la
cinquième fois en tête du championnat du
monde des pilotes de formule 1 il égale
ainsi le record établi dans les années
50 par l'argentin juan manuel fangio
explications genia ball
d'habitude si réservé michael schumacher
dans les bras de jean todt laisse couler
des larmes de joie en remportant le
grand prix de france à magny cours il
décroche un cinquième titre de champion
du monde avant même la fin du
championnat
comment je me sens 5
j'ai jamais été bon dans les moments où
il faut trouver les mots appropriés
tout ça ça me dépasse et chaste et sauve
mais personne ne croyait à sa victoire
surtout après cette erreur à la sortie
des stands franchissement nuits blanches
pas de retrait de permis mais une
pénalité
le pilote allemand repart de plus belle
et pousse à la faute le finlandais
raikkonen schumacher a fait parler
l'expérience
aussitôt à carpène le village natal des
sous-marins heures tout le monde a fêté
cet exploit même son de cloche à
maranello en italie le siège de ferrari
avec ce cinquième titre
michael schumacher égale le record de
l'argentin juan manuel fangio et on
entre dans la légende du sport
automobile à lille métropole première
épreuve et première médaille d'or pour
la france aux championnats du monde
d'athlétisme handisport grâce au lanceur
de poids qui rit simone cette
manifestation sportive est la plus
importante jamais réalisée en france
dans le domaine du sport christophe
duchiron et frédéric bazille ne croyez
pas que l'orage s'accompagne toujours du
désespoir
samedi lors de la cérémonie d'ouverture
des championnats du monde certes pour la
pluie les 1200 athlètes ont été servis à
20 c trempé mais rigolard en imper
transparent malgré la grêle les coups de
tonnerre il savait qu'après la pluie
viendrait le bon temps
ces types à la mine réjouissante sont
des forts en tout effort en muscles et
pour les décibels des forts en gueule il
faut dire que chez ces gens là quand on
lance le poids en sept ans faire des
kilos avec décrypte féroce saeed
paraît-il ce matin à l'heure de la messe
c'était l'heure des lanceurs catégorie
infirme moteur cérébral en piste le
français tire ici bonne à son troisième
essai il envoie le poids de 4 kg à 14
mai 33 nouveaux records du monde est luc
l'ancien record c'était déjà lui c'est
vous dire si ce jovial athlète avait le
moral
enfin motivent ceux qui vont devoir
suivre derrière avec avec cet exploit
que quand je viens de réaliser
je sais que mes coéquipiers par derrière
ça va donner du punch pour eux quoi dans
son genre thierry cibone est une
curiosité et lance ici mis sur le tard
mais en deux saisons il a déjà tout
gagné d'une force incroyable
ce néo calédoniens d'origine fait un
parfait cousin d'obélix le gaulois
au festival d'avignon la danse prend le
relais du théâtre dans la cour d'honneur
jusqu'à la fin du festival c'est la
jeune chorégraphe allemande sasha waltz
qui occupe la cour du palais des papes
elle propose une création sur le corps
la foule est l'individu daniel wolfromm
et thierry breton nico a network of
ultimes réglages avant la première la
chorégraphe sasha valls seul face à sa
troupe
l'immense cour d'honneur du palais des
papes par et engloutir la jeune
berlinoise
mais c'est bien elle le maître de
cérémonie
la danse est un acte physique par
essence la chorégraphe doit donner de sa
personne pour convaincre encore et
encore de ces options répétition
générale en costumes
la façade du palais est mise à
contribution un des thèmes de cette
pièce la foule est l'individu houle
inverse quand il est si difficile de nos
jours de se distinguer
la chorégraphie se nomme nobody
personnes en anglais
j'ai essayé de donner le sentiment que
personne signifie tout le monde dans le
sens où vous perdez votre identité comme
indivision dérouté et déjanté l'individu
et canton du ciel une machinerie aussi
énorme
la foule elle même perd le nord il n'y a
plus personne
à
et même s'il est immense il est n'est
pas aussi grands espaces au tout je
pense qu'il donne une idée du volume
une sorte d' espace enfin la chorégraphe
a donc créé cette pièce pour occuper un
maximum d'espacé possible
avignon et sa cour d'honneur sont bien à
la dimension de son ambition en
haute-corse les 5e rencontres
internationales de théâtre créée par le
comédien robin renucci se déroule en ce
moment une centaine de stagiaires
prépare plus de 20 spectacles
cette initiative de théâtre populaire a
permis à cette région désertée de
connaître un nouvel essor
reportage marie-hélène bono et j'aurais
me l'a 104 stagiaires ils viennent
d'autriche de belgique de lituanie du
tout groupe d'ad et de france bien sûr
dont 21 de corse
pour la cinquième année consécutive ils
investissent les villages de la balagne
en répétition ici dans le parc du seul
hôtel de la région sous l'oeil curieux
du patro le théâtre transforme le monde
vivre ensemble l'expérience théâtrale
transforme la vie et lorsque la vie est
transformée et que les gens peuvent
enfin mieux être là où ils sont grâce au
théâtre et bien ces générateurs ces
générateurs de vie tout simplement donc
deux quotidiens le boulanger fait plus
de pain le teulier fait plus de
réceptions de chambre et l'aubergiste
plus de repas le pain le boulanger en
fait en cette période 7 à 800 par jour
contre une centaine en hiver seulement
trois fois par semaine autre entreprise
locale qui trouve son compte cette
fabrique artisanale de gâteaux corse
en été elle double sa production et la
présence des stagiaires étrangers lui
permet d'être connu hors des frontières
ce moment saveurs train de renée coincé
parce qu'avec la même heure c'est dur
tout à la main environ le travail c'est
artisanal et et il ya beaucoup de monde
de la corse elle est multipliée par dix
plus on exporte beaucoup et en ce moment
on est très coincé voilà vous avez en un
sens je me rêve ça se termine aussi vite
le canton compte 250 habitants une
région désertifier autrefois ce qui
reliait les villages entre eux c'était
la transhumance là c'est la parole
désormais du des auteurs des poètes
transporté qui fait se réunir les gens
autour du théâtre dans les villages des
montagnes qui sont à côté
l'office du tourisme s'est agrandie deux
campings et des gîtes ruraux vos
souvenirs
une dizaine d'emplois ont déjà été créés
grâce à ces rencontres théâtrales en
2003 les travaux de construction du
théâtre vont commencer il devrait voir
le jour début 2005
en attendant d'ici le 10 août 22
spectacles seront créés au pied des
montagnes en meurthe et moselle a semblé
me rassemblements de petits avions en
tout genre pour la plupart construits
par des amateurs
mille quatre cents pilotes devraient
participer à ce rassemblement des
habitués qui aiment revenir tous les ans
pour comparer leurs coûts coûts
charlotte mise si tout se passe bien et
et lissage dans quelques instants sur
l'aérodrome de chambley
ici les participants viennent par les
airs comme jean-pierre notre pilote qui
arrive des ebooks après plus de deux
heures de vol
voyez si on la tâche pas essayer un coup
de vent cette nuit là on risque de le
retrouver sur le goût son avion a brillé
les années 60 c'est lui qui l'a
restaurée c'est une pièce unique en
europe
tous les ans ils l'exposent à chambley
où il retrouve d'autres constructeurs
amateurs qui pour certains ont fabriqué
leur avion de toutes pièces mais il faut
être ingénieur pour construire un avion
comme ça pas du tout sinon il y aurait
pas beaucoup d'avions d'amateurs d'aller
dans les constructeurs amateurs vous
avez toutes les couches de la société ne
faut pas se tromper par m si vous vous
trompez vous recommencez quand vous
louper une pièce vous leur faites m'en
tombent
un temps de dire non quand on loupe une
pièce si on ne monte pas sur la maison
on la refait avant de la mettre dessus
hyper sourit cet avion en kit ou
ménestrel 1500 aéronefs participaient à
ce rassemblement annuel légendaire qui
existe depuis 55 ans on peut le faire
ici les pilotes viennent échanger des
tuyaux ils ont en général l'âge de la
manifestation mais c'est en train de
changer
on a aussi et de plus en plus des jeunes
qui avant d'être mariée d'avoir des
enfants bien dit j'aime construire mon
avion mais non ça coûte pas cher c'est
le prix d'une voiture on peut se
construire un avion pour 10000 euros
dix mille euros et 3000 heures au
minimum pour construire un avion alors
pour les plus pressés il y à une autre
solution acheter d'occasion et rentrer
dans le club des pilotes propriétaires
de chambley pour avoir comme jean-pierre
le plaisir de ses valises dans les airs
c'est la fin de ce journal dans un
instant la météo n'a fait les rues ou et
20h50 30 vies avec rufus 00h50 dernier
journal présenté par jean claude renault
demain à 7h40 dans les 4 vérités
jean-paul chapelle recevra pour la
campagne anti sida le président de aides
christian saout 13h le journal laurence
ostolaza 20 heures antoine cormery
excellente soirée sur france 2 bonsoir